this is Pamela Ray Schuler she's a
stand-up comedian and we're about to
watch stand up that's medically relevant
and she's going to explain it to you and
I'm going to explain the jokes let's get
started
I am fully medicated now anybody else
antidepressants medication I don't know
how I feel when comedians make that joke
why you shouldn't ever be upset that
you're taking a medicine but celebrating
that you're taking no it normalizes it
how many people are going to see this
and be like oh my gosh I don't need to
be ashamed yes but then how many people
are going to request medicines that they
don't yet need and then it's up to
people like you that's true it's a lot
of weight on my doctors well no it
points to the fine line between breaking
the stigma and not spreading
misinformation or celebrating who she is
and what she's going through I'm not
anything against celebration I thought I
was on an antidepressant it turns out
I'm not it turns out I'm actually on a
mood stabilizer that they use as an
antidepressant fun fact about
prescription drugs everything they
prescribe they actually use for like
four different things that's true and
not only do we use it for four different
things some don't even have an FDA
approval for those things like they
haven't been adequately studied so we
use them off label I know that because
I've been on so many ads for Tourette's
that are not for Tourette's because a
study showed that it might help
Tourette's when I was 12 I wore the
nicotine patch because there was a study
did it help no it just made me Jones
okay well we had to try something you're
out of control otherwise so you don't
really know what your deal is until you
find a combo that works and then Google
all your pills by yourself so after
years of trial and error I finally found
a combination of things that worked for
me I don't want people to try it on
themselves yeah because a lot of these
medications have really bad interactions
so you have to have a thorough knowledge
of how they interact with each other
like if a patient of mine is on three
psychoactive medications I get them a
psychiatrist ASAP okay that's smart
because it's just there's so many
interactions that I'm not well versed
enough to know how to have the
experience to know how they that's
important and six months ago I decided
to Google it because what the hell and
it turns out that everything I'm taking
is primarily used for bipolar disorder
so I went back to my psychiatrist and I
was like hey
do we think we
at least and she was like oh yeah
they never had that discussion before
that's terrifying to me how many things
do you think my therapist thinks I have
and just hasn't told me but why would
they not tell you do you ask oh all the
time she'll write something down I'll be
like what are you writing but see like I
hate labels because the labels aren't
really for the benefit of the patient
they're for the insurance company the
legal stuff but really a person is not a
diagnosis so I agree with you 100 I
think so often especially when we work
with kids we're always trying to find a
diagnosis instead of just like getting
to know someone for who they are and
treating symptoms of things we're seeing
but I do think sometimes knowledge is
power do you think it could become a
self-fulfilling prophecy where you think
I am ex so I must behave as X yes so
that's awesome yeah but I like yeah yeah
so it's it's individualized it's a
balancing act I said you really didn't
know that I was bipolar and she goes no
of course not we thought we were
treating anxiety and depression and I
said okay because this kind of feels
like a putting your dog's medication in
cheese situation
when I was in high school I was like Dad
I think I'm depressed and he was like
you just need some protein get a scoop
of peanut butter that's like every
Health influencer on Tick Tock Health
influence I think yeah buy my protein or
it's taken by my hormone
you think I'm making that mine would be
amazing yeah do you want to buy some of
my hormones Mike yes but yours aren't
hormones they're horny modes
there's a reason you're a doctor yeah
who makes jokes yeah there's a lot of
dads out there just white knuckling it
through life right now
clinging to a jar of chunky Jiff like
it's the answer just a buoy in the storm
I'll pass that's a joke with a lot of
medical meaning behind it tell me more
men will oftentimes experience their
depression or show their depression to
the world in different ways than what we
describe traditionally in medical stuff
so for example some will develop
addiction to going to the gym to taking
steroids and getting huge some will get
up gambling addiction some will become
abusive in their relationships but
really what they're experiencing is
depression and they're acting out look
at me learning yeah and that was
interesting so I was like actively
listening yeah that was good I don't
know if you were faking it you were
really good no you know and I'm faking
it
okay my doctor comes in
he doesn't say hello he doesn't say good
morning he just walks in he points at me
which is super aggressive our doctor's
ever that aggressive to you sorry um he
is still my type that that's oh really
smash or pass oh smashed and he goes do
you want something for your hair
and I go what
and he goes do you want something for
your hair and I go I don't get it
and he goes says nobody told you that
your hair's falling out
foreign
I was like damn
no it's a doctor Rose I want my whole
life being okay with my face and then a
doctor said
um how do you feel about your weak chin
well maybe you should do some squats
and he goes you weigh 245 and I go like
yeah like I knew that he goes you weigh
230 last time you were here not exactly
what I would call weight loss I'm like
are we at a few own roast or something
like what are you doing old school
doctors used to think this works then he
says you know you're the fattest patient
I've seen all day no
foreign
and I go it's 9 30 in the morning
I would do a murder he's like you know
we ran your blood work it turns out your
muscle enzymes are through the roof and
I go yeah man like I'm super strong like
how is that a problem well muscle
enzymes happen when there's like rapid
breakdown of the muscle okay it's a
condition called Rhabdomyolysis spell it
r h a b o d
o
m-y-o-l-y-s-i-s sting no I'm just
kidding I don't know I don't know the
myoglobin that's released actually can
be nephrotoxic so it's problematic to
your kidneys this happens when people
who don't exercise for a while go and
start exercising oh okay or if people
are found down like elderly people for a
long period of time and their muscles
breaking down or if you take a lot of
drugs and you shiver a lot or something
like that where you overuse your muscles
do you use words with your patients like
nephrotoxic when I say nephrotoxic I
followed up with kidney injury
immediately after my brain was still
stuck on
do you have a ring on your finger and I
go yeah and he goes you're married
and I go yeah and he goes to a guy
and I go no and he goes oh I thought you
were gay and I go why and he goes hey
I'm just kidding and I go that's fine he
goes but check it out and he takes my
chart and he shows it to me and he had
written gay question mark on my medical
chart I really feel like this is a joke
or a lie because a chart is a medical
legal record you're not going to write
gay question mark on it yeah I'd be
exclamation unless unless unless unless
unless he saw that Tom segor is a
comedian he tried to be funny in a
really poor attempt to doctors out there
don't don't do that yeah don't do that
but people ask me dumb questions all the
time I'll get this one a lot they'll be
like hey Ryan
is that genetic
yes uh because you see my mom was Irish
and my dad was a lobster
[Laughter]
kids are the worst though oh kids are
the absolute worst though because kids
don't have that filter you know if a kid
says you're ugly you're ugly all right
deal with it buy a hat I don't know what
to tell you uh but this little girl
after she saw me and after she screamed
after screamed it was a big scream uh
which side note has led me to a new game
that I play uh now when I'm out in
public and I see a child staring at my
arms I like to pretend that I'm
discovering them for the first time too
someone on the subway recently goes
you're short and I go
where'd the rest of me go for four years
my wife and I couldn't get pregnant
oh I've heard this and it was my fault
what's going on with you and Bina you're
like Indian Barbie and Kent
and I'm like I know
and much like Ken
what because Kenneth has no I have art
in my apartment this is very much Pam
art and it's Barbie and Ken in a motel
room and Barbie's on the bed and Ken is
standing there and they're both naked
Barbies and the caption just says
disappointed Barbie ah there's a lot of
doctors
are my age
and they're Indian which means I might
know that so we're sitting there in the
waiting room at NYU right door opens
nurse comes out
she's like Dr Gupta will see you now I'm
like oh this better not be Arjun from
Sacramento
I hear a familiar voice he's like
awesome man hush I'm like this is
Sacramento is that his boy I went to
middle school together
yeah
he's not even an MD
he's a goddamn deal why is he so angry
about that I never understood heard you
throw the computer yeah well why so this
dude is all up in my merchandise he's
like oh bro I know what's wrong I'm like
stop saying bro he's like son oh
much blood down there it's lowering your
sperm count so we're going to do a
dangerous surgery called varicoseal
repair a varicocele is basically a
swelling of your veins in your scrotum
we used to say like if you feel that
area it feels like a bag of worms can
you think of a more poop so much for
that visual that's what that's what they
taught us in medical school Stu pulls
out a trimmer he goes let me shave you
down right now
let's do this right here right now I go
Archer back up I'm not ready
he goes listen man
if you don't get this surgery
you can't have kids
ever
go are you serious
life gets very real when don't want
becomes can't have
isn't that right deals he's so anti-deo
which is funny because in this clip the
do ends up allowing him to conceive yeah
to be clear I'm not at all anti-dia I'm
I'm Pro I don't I don't think he's
anti-deo either I think he's just making
a joke yes but it's just at the cost of
doctors in the midst of a pandemic when
doctors were on the front lines that's
totally fair terrible like look as a
comedian you gotta know comedic timing
yes and if you're gonna make a joke
about doctors
Pig pandemic okay my dermatologist said
he needed to do a biopsy of a little uh
mole on the tip of my nose I was about
to say you don't need a dermatologist in
some cases like I can do that but not if
it's on the face because I'm worried
about scars yeah wow that sounds like
it's gonna hurt
he said don't worry we're gonna numb it
first with a painkiller
I said how he said we're going to
puncture a sharp needle into the tip of
your nose when I work with patients and
they need a small procedure done
sometimes I'm going to say like I think
it might be best to go without
anesthesia because anesthesia might hurt
more than the procedure I had to get a
little thing removed and she did the
anesthesia she gave the shot and then
she started slicing and I started
immediately crying and like you have to
wait and she goes well it takes 15
minutes to kick in and I was like then
wait 15 minutes when I did my annoy germ
rotation you would inject patients
lidocaine move on to the next patient
figure out what's going on go back to
that patient do the procedure
and at the hospital I said excuse me can
I have pain medication because I am not
thriving and the nurse said oh okay and
he gives me the IV and he gives me a
little pump of something I was like Yum
Yum Yum Yum yes she's alive and I was
like actually no I still passed away
what the [ __ ] was that and he said it
was a placebo it was a saline injection
and I said sir my ankle looks like a
U-turn you better give me something
and I don't know if you guys know this
but black and brown people are
prescribed opioids at a lower rate than
white people so white people have a
higher addiction rate to heroin and I
said to myself huh
maybe sometimes racism's good
I will say it's a double-edged sword
let's say you're in a community where I
worked in like new work you have
patients that come in that you know are
at high risk because of their
environment for developing an opioid
addiction if you're a good doctor you
should know that if you live in a white
suburban community you're also at a high
risk okay but yeah being aware of
someone's risks and tailoring their
medication plan is actually good okay so
in this case the doctor that's assuming
that because someone's white they have a
lower risk is factually inaccurate and
therefore has led to worse outcomes so
to advices work against you now when
racism works for you you know what I'm
saying I do before major surgery I asked
if I could get something to take the
edge off I already had an IV in and I
was like you can give me all something
we're running late I was like freaking
out and they said no and then I started
barking and then I got it then it went
from like a scary day to such a fun day
I was telling jokes I did stand up for I
would have rather you called me and I
would have just held your head uh people
will say I'm a medication okay they're
lying I I started walking in my sleep I
was living with my girlfriend at the
time and I started having a recurring
dream that there was a hovering insect
like Jackal in our bedroom I had the
same dream but it wasn't a jackal it was
you that's because I was there I was
just like I did buy a book it was called
the promise of sleep and I learned that
there are 78 known Sleep Disorders
things that range from sleep apnea to
night terrors to narcolepsy narcolepsy
is terrifying because there are people
who fall asleep at any time I think
there's more than 78
disorders how many do you have primarily
one insomnia yeah yeah
anxiety induced mostly and I read about
this thing called REM behavior disorder
where people have a dopamine deficiency
that's a chemical that's released from
your brain into your body when you fall
asleep it paralyzes your body so you
don't do
what's in your brand interesting I don't
know if that's a hundred percent proven
or the leading theory basically when you
fall asleep and you enter REM stage your
muscles are supposed to become paralyzed
so you don't move during the stage of
your sleep while you're drinking that's
why I don't hit Ram
uh Tourette Tourette Tourette Tourette
yeah so do you not feel refreshed when
you wake up not very often now five
years ago I'm in Walla Walla Washington
and I'm staying which is a place and I'm
staying at a hotel called La Quinta Inn
and I fall asleep
and I I have a dream
that there is a guided missile headed
towards my motel room and there was all
these military personnel in the room
with me I jump out of bed so I decided
in my dream and as it turns out in my
life
to jump out my window oh no there are
two important details one I was on the
second floor
two the window was closed
so I jumped through a window and I
screamed ah and it's like not like one
of those action movies where the window
gets blown up before you jump through it
no he's literally flying through a
window and I got up
and I kept running
and I'm running and I'm slowly realizing
I'm on the front lawn of La Quinta Inn
in waia Washington in my underwear
bleeding and I'm like oh no what does it
say about him maybe men that it took him
literally jumping out of a window to be
like maybe I should get some help for
this well that's literally what I was
gonna say that like when people ask me
when is the time that you should see a
doctor that's the time I would say one
day before that yeah but it's hard to
predict sometimes but that's that's the
definite line and the next morning I
flew back to New York and I did what I
should have done in the first place when
I saw the Jackal I went to a doctor who
specializes in Sleep disorders and and I
was diagnosed with REM behavior disorder
and so now when I go to bed at night I
take medication and I sleep and I'm not
making this up in a sleeping bag
up to my neck
and I wear mittens
so I can't open the sleeping bag there's
got to be a better solution that sounds
so comfortable no it doesn't yes it does
I'm struggling to escape small spaces
wrap me up like a burrito really yeah
with gloves that you're unable to open
yeah the problem is is a single woman I
they would then find me six years later
like that's literally what I do to
babies when they know when they scratch
their faces and then and then when you
um babies in the morning they go
so like I said I have Tourette Syndrome
the best one
what's right I pick up
pick up us so you're about to see Matrix
guitar
s camera watch
this twitch gets me in trouble my
roommate came home from work I was like
yo
our neighbor died
he said did you kill him
I was like nah
it's no it's the my Customs joke where
he asked if I'm bringing anything
illegal back into the country and I was
like no
click here for when Pam reads thirsty
tweets to me
enjoy this one follow Pam and as always
stay happy
and healthy and fabulous yay
[Music]